I know Peter is being very very strong
and their sums reported on events around
the world now he's at the center of a
story his parents can barely comprehend
we are devastated shocked and dismayed
at this finding we are not usually a
family of superlatives but I have to say
this morning my vocabulary fails to
convey just how shattered we are in the
presence of the parties the court has
sentenced Mohamed Fahmy bahir Mohamed
and Peter greste to a seven-year
aggravated prison sentence will shadow
abrasion in Australian Peter greste and
his two colleagues from al-jazeera were
convicted in Cairo of spreading false
news in a verdict which has caused
outrage journalism is not a crime
or you should all be behind bars it's as
simple as that
this man our son Peter is an
award-winning journalist he's not a
criminal he's not a criminal Australia's
Prime Minister has joined the
international outcry and is demanding
action it is important that decisions be
made on a fair and just basis so we will
be talking to the grest of family we
will be talking to the Egyptian
government about what we can do to try
to ensure that Peter greste comes home
as quickly as possible you can never
prepare yourself for something as
painful as this
however we are absolutely determined and
committed to continue this battle until
Peter as well as his colleagues are all
out of prison and free to do and go
wherever they decide but an appeal may
take many months Egypt says it's on the
road to democracy for the loved ones of
those convicted that's an impossible
message to believe Jonathan Samuels Sky
News Sydney